[Music]
first of all i just wanted to say uh
it's an honor to be doing this stop uh
you know i'm no i'm i'm i'm really
really happy and i appreciate the
opportunity so i'll i'll do my best well
people were asking for a collab
for some time and also i my logic was
you know i've taken some lessons before
from like coaches privately
and i kind of was like i feel like i
feel like this could be fun because this
is this will be a high level lesson but
we both have an ability to break it down
to a uh you know to a intermediate or
beginner level so
i i think it'll be good
yeah i think it'll be good too and
you're right that the positions that we
do are going to be you know obviously
pretty complex but i also think we're
going to be funny
and you know we're not going to hold
back
and hopefully people will appreciate
that i've got you know so much material
that i've built up over the last year
and it's so fun to share them with
someone who can appreciate
good exercises and good positions
so i'm i'm super excited about this too
i was thinking that we could we could
start with like a warm-up study
and then go from there to our our main
theme which today is going to be uh
converting winning positions
how does that how does that sound that
sounds great if i could do more of that
i would be like
i would be it would be a god
unfortunately i uh
i don't do a whole lot of that so you
mean study solving
oh no no no converting winning positions
converting winning positions oh well
that they are yeah yeah yeah i i i think
it is my biggest weakness especially
like in time constraint uh
because i think my playing style i'm
like a walmart narrow
you know like you're you're narrow and i
like i get to interesting positions but
i just have no ability to convert them
so yeah i'll let you take it away i'm in
live so i guess you'll invite me to some
analysis border
yeah i'm inviting you right now
okay so let me give you a very
interesting position
in which you kind of have to deal with
chaos and i think that's honestly one of
the hardest
tasks is when you can sense that you're
winning you're attacking
but you actually have to zero in on very
specific ideas
well you're not joking it's it's
it's all soviet database this is yeah
literally ussr championships
so this is white to play and why does
that why does downer rook why to
sacrifice the rook but obviously the
attack you have a huge attack against
black's king but you have to find an
only move
every other move
you know relinquishes relinquishes the
attacker allows black to
to draw the game
was like a pierce or like a kings indian
or something
this was a yeah i think this was
appearance
you have every every every pawn
important for the
right single pawn that's important um
okay so white to play i'll let you think
another guess would be what would what
was black's last move
that i actually can't even help you with
um
okay
i would suggest that people in the chat
take a little bit of time too because
this is a hard position you won't solve
this in five seconds
all right
i don't even know where the where the
hell i'm supposed to start right what
are you
well again you need to start by trying
to figure out
what the attacking ideas are
and
you know
what are you know you should come up
with one or two tempting candidate moves
so when you start the calculation
process sometimes
uh you know the position solves itself
almost even if you don't realize that
that's happening
yeah so just sort of start somewhere and
you'll go from there
all right
um
i actually have to think about this one
i don't want to like start saying things
out loud no no no no rush at all
yeah so my my my first instinct was you
know
queen e5 rook d8 bishop e6
etc etc right
um
i think that that entire line is
actually kind of interesting but it just
doesn't work because at the end of the
variation black can play
rook d7 or
king f7 if you really want king f7 is
probably the most annoying move white
just runs out of pieces
yeah anything or takes yeah takes in
queen e6
yeah
so
yeah i mean in terms of another idea
you have like various night moves you
have like knight of knight f5
knight h5
i guess
what is black's next move going to be
that's a good way to
avoid getting overwhelmed if it's black
to move what is black playing yeah
that's that's generally what what i do
if i can't think of something black is
gonna go queen e4
and white is gonna lose or maybe black
will play knight f7 knight e f7
yeah that's another good consolidating
move
but i think queen e4
right so queen e4 is the biggest threat
if you allow queen e4 and you have
nothing against it the threat of queen
h1
it's gonna cause white's position to
collapse
yeah so you need to think in a very
targeted way
about
some sort of prophylaxis but it can't i
mean the move can't be rookie one
because like that's way way way too slow
so this needs to be some sort of
tactical prophylaxis against queen takes
e4
and that's
do you see it
that is a very promising sound um
well now that i started thinking a
little bit more i don't think i exactly
see it but
no actually the move that i thought was
correct is maybe definitely not oh
oh wait a minute
wait a minute
hold on i'm i'm holding my breath
is
okay i really want to go knight e8 with
the idea of f7
98 queen takes c4 f7 and the point is if
you take with the knight you get mated
and if you take with the king you get
forked yeah but it's not over because 98
knight df7 right so now the execution
phase 98 knight df7 you're at a dead end
but the next question can i execute this
idea in a different way
right
yeah that's why i said i
i got excited because i thought it was
uh you know it was that but i knew
immediately it was not that
unfortunately
um but don't abandon the idea do you
have a way to do the same thing
in a different way
um
or something similar in a different way
yeah
i'm thinking um
i suppose you can start with f7
uh if one of the
knight d takes knight e takes sorry
knight e takes knight e takes yeah then
i guess
98 or knight h5
but i take your bishop there
oh jesus sorry takes h6 yeah my my
my brain was like 98 is creating the
threat of a fork it's not it's only
creating the threat of a fork if queen
takes e4
no it is oh because f7 queen f7
yeah
uh okay
but the thing is after f7 knight f7
right look at that position very very
closely the king is actually checkmated
knight f5
okay
knight f5 queen e4 f7
so if the night df7 mate but there's
knight e takes but don't stop
calculating knight e takes f7 look at
that position
yeah knight ef7
um
uh
maybe
some queen f3 move
simpler than that you want to get rid of
black's queen right that's the objective
right
so achieve the objective in the most
straightforward way in that position
because queen g2
but why are you using the queen
right if you want to attack the queen
you should try to use the piece of of
least value
but i i didn't want to go bishop g2 well
then queen takes f5 but you're
forgetting about a certain piece you're
just forgetting about a certain piece
rookie one yeah
yeah okay i just didn't want to allow
queen h1 but i guess there's queen f2
there's just king f2 yeah king of two
king of two yeah yeah exactly knight f5
prophylaxis against queen takes c4 f7
if knight df7 then 97 is checkmate if
king f7 there is a fork and if knight
ef7 this is a really hard move
right so your instinct was not to allow
this move right that was the reason you
yeah yeah i was well my first thought
was like
you know go queen i guess rookie one is
also good because knight e7 is just
defended now on top of everything else
right um
actually if you play like queen f3
black can just maybe even take the
bishop or something right that's there's
no mate anymore rookie one actually
creates a threat
uh yeah oh yeah queen f3 i can play like
gf or something
or yes yeah yeah no but then back to g3
i guess
gf queen g3 check
okay but queen g2 for example you can
just take the bishop
or take the queen and take the knight
yeah see i like i'm
way beyond uh yeah oh my god and then i
don't d8 defense b7 yeah this position
was uh oh my god that was a hard
position but but um
i think one of the keys is also not to
just be afraid of moves and to really
examine whether they carry a threat so
one key insight that you'd have to reach
in this position is that queen h1 isn't
actually dangerous so you have time
uh that's a question you can ask
yourself in many positions do i have
time
like do you have time do you have two or
three tempi that you can use to make
relatively slow moves
does that does that kind of make sense
yeah yeah yeah that makes sense so in
the game
this the hard part for me about this
position was like sometimes when i don't
know what to do i do
switch the mode i'm like oh my opponent
wants to play
this and this and i have to stop that
but but i but i do it in the wrong
moment like this was the kind of game
where i should have done that faster
because i it looks like i have just too
many moves
um
sometimes i do that and i and i
shouldn't have i should have just
focused on kind of my own
resources right
yeah
but the time question i think is very
valuable because sometimes you get a
situation where you can sense that
you're completely winning and um
you know you know those positions where
the correct move is like super super
quiet
and you're like i would never find such
a move but in reality thinking
prophylactically in positions where
you're completely winning is a very good
approach like sometimes you have a huge
attack and if you can just eliminate one
little idea the attack essentially plays
itself but if you keep trying to win by
force and beat your head against the
wall then things get really really
complicated there's a very instructive
position on that topic that i that i
just found which i
uh which i've known about for a while i
really like this
it's uh some buoyancy so this canadian
gm upset played him yeah yeah
and
he found a really really impressive move
in this position where it is very
obvious that white is like one step away
from delivering checkmate
but only one move wins very cleanly
try to find it
you're like
wow
uh that knight on d7 looking kind of
yeah i played i played bator
he's a very funny guy
yeah um he uh
he he i think he's pretty well known uh
in canada he's uh he he uh
when he does like analysis after the
game
so he's always very intensely saying
that he's winning
oh so
a disciple of kramnik
yeah yeah yeah like against me he's like
no it's just nearly
and likely was like right there he's
like aren't you down three pawns right
very unclear and the other gm was like
uh
i think you're just down three pounds oh
well like oh it's like unclear no but i
mean it's like the cr do you know the
kramnik ding press conference that makes
me laugh so hard
yeah
no but i still come in somehow and then
ding is like the knight of five like or
whatever
and then anastasia carlos is just like
asking him a question uh she's like you
agree no
yeah
he's just like no and then he's laughing
and ding is laughing because he or she
knows kramnik's just full of it right
now oh you know what my favorite clip is
it's it's one of vichy uh there's a
couple of clips where vishy gets
frustrated with the questions and he's
like the nicest guy ever
uh so when he gets angry it's really
funny so there's one clip where
the eating dinner
yeah yeah the eating dinner one and then
i don't i don't know why you don't
understand english
[Laughter]
yeah yeah he got he it was so funny i
mean he got so frustrated with the uh
but what are you really calculating the
variations no i was thinking what to eat
tonight
okay so white to play so what is the
most tempting move here and why does it
not work
knight f6 takes takes knight f5
if you extract the wisdom from that line
then you've essentially already solved
this position
that's actually all you need to solve it
is that one line
that's kind of what i think but uh you
know i'm i'm trying um
well
yeah there's a there's a lot of i don't
know it seems like there's still a lot
of ideas though um
but the only serious defensive resource
that black has is knight f5 right
everything else is gives you a lot of
time to assemble your forces
yeah which
makes me think
it's like bishop h3
um but then knight e4 it feels like
there's no knight f6 anymore
or 98 okay so let's consider that bishop
h3
98 what do you make of this position
i mean it looks like [ __ ] but right rook
d4 rook h4 probably is for example rook
d4 ends the game immediately
yeah
um
knight and if knight e4 instead of 98
maybe the same thing rook d4 i just i i
don't see how black defends the position
f5
yeah he's something
you can probably take the knight or you
can play i would imagine gf and then
knight f6 h4 there should be six also
yeah oh yeah or bishop e6 and remember
the point i made about time right how am
i so confident that this is winning it's
because even if you pass
black is nowhere near even assembling
his defensive forces like you're not
even close to consolidating
yeah
yeah which is why bishop h3 i i i man i
just stay away from moves like that for
some i'm like yeah bishop h3 i mean i i
just assume i'm missing something like
maybe there's
f5
and
but intuitively you should
understand that this is like yeah gf for
example
yeah
f4 yeah f4 yeah you don't even go for
mate you can just and that's actually
another very important insight in these
positions which is that
you often shouldn't even bother going
for made you should just go for
material gain in such positions
and that is the actually the safest way
of winning because if you're up 800
pieces you know the game is over whereas
if you start hunting from eight you get
into time pressure you start getting
nervous etc etc
yeah so bishop h3 i mean but i feel like
that's not the end of the story unless
it is it is bishop h3 and way you resign
in two moves
after
what did he what was this
world cup i think he played 98
yeah he played uh he played
rook fda rook d4 and resigns wow
that's it for us
but tours best win
oh totally and then he lost the next
game and he lost the match but uh
he came very very well
he won with white which is impressive
but it's not like when you win with
black in the first game because that's
that's like when you're basically a win
in the match right
no
that must be like the most
nerve-wracking feeling ever
like the feeling of beating someone like
a needing a draw on demand
who's the highest rated player you beat
in classical
caruana i actually beat my two two
highest rated players in i i'd only
beaten one twenty seven hundred before
the us championship was yakovenko who
was like 27 40 when i played him
and then jeffrey was 2700 on the dot and
fabio was 2800 on the dot
kind of funny
wow what about before those guys
yakovanko yucca jose had never beaten a
2700 other than yakivenko where'd you
play him
uh world team championship
world team championship yeah yeah you
you probably talked about it in your
recap of beating of beating fabi but how
how nervous were you
so i was basically shooting my pants to
be completely honest
i mean it was like
there was a moment when i could sense
that if my calculations were correct the
game was over and that was the most
nerve-wracking moment of all because
before then it didn't become real
but when i started calculating the
variations in the end game
and uh
and i understood that if i was
calculating everything correctly it was
a win there were some incredible lines
there i mean i could i could show it at
some point i don't want to make it make
this about me though so
there were some incredible lines there
and
you know i was like if i make one little
mistake here
white could be winning actually
so i was just walking around the playing
hall like i couldn't even look at the
board
to be honest
so
okay so
this is raymond keane against leonid
stein who is actually one of my favorite
soviet players very little known
probably people in the chat are like who
stein was a very dynamic player and he
was
you know in another if his health was
better i think he would have had you
know a great shot of becoming world
champion like he was that good black to
play
okay i was really hoping we were playing
black because if we were playing white
that looked uh
yeah that this converting that position
my first thing my favorite thing to do
when i get a position is to count how
many pawns we each have
i'm like six six all right right
material is equal even though it almost
looks like black is up material
first instinct
play some
rook f3 move
uh
but bishop f3 and
i don't really i mean
i don't see much beyond that point
uh right rook f3 i mean rook f3 bishop
three the only thing i would consider is
queen g5 there
for no other reason than like that's the
only move that i can see continuing my
attack
um
but i wouldn't play that because there's
yeah it's it's it's it's it's a little
bit amorphous it's unclear but what's
your next move going to be after queen
g5 see that's the thing knight e3
ah
but what if i play like rook takes c7
there
yeah that's well that's what i was
looking at um
right like
93 king h2 there i think it gets really
complicated
it gets
super complicated but i i
i don't dislike it i mean 93 king h2
queen h6 so let's look at the board
because i'm really really skeptical of
that line
yeah
yeah no i mean me too
i'm just saying like
um
you you can probably even play like rook
f1 queen g5 rook f1 i mean i'm not
saying you we should i don't know i'm
sorry sorry i thought the rook was
defending okay it's been a long lesson
i thought the rook was defended by the
rook that's not oh oh i see i see okay
actually let me let me offer uh
an interesting idea what if i just take
yeah that's okay so bishop takes
i just saw this i saw that you can just
kill my fun queen h5 i guess i have to
play
yeah queen h2
queen g5
right
rookie one rookie one and i think that's
it that's my attack yeah white already
should start thinking about playing this
but again i don't i'm not trying to be
you know an [ __ ] and just be
skeptical of every sacrifice it's just a
question of necessity right like do you
need to
like you should only go for this if
you're absolutely positive that the
attack is overwhelming
because otherwise you can almost make a
slow move and preserve the attack well
the other the only other option to get
the queen involved is like
you know c6
okay
so now we're getting somewhere
yeah
how does that line go that's a great
question i actually have no clue what
white's next move is so let's say bc
queen b6 continue
i guess d4
okay
good uh
well
my first instinct is to take the knight
again but then the king gets to h1 and i
don't see anything there there's no
continuation there so yeah so c6bc queen
b6 track d4
i guess you just take on d4 but there
might be some a5 move or a five or same
same concept try to get the queen off of
b6
by forcing the queen
trade well queen b5 queen b5 defense
and actually the position is just equal
there i can make the moves on the board
c6 b6
i mean yeah it's a nasty move exactly
yeah
i don't think that's the end of the
story i mean like d4 you gotta there's
there's still work to be done though um
yeah the position just gets really
complicated but
black is not even necessarily better
here
so
but you don't take on d4 is there
anything to calculate beyond that
uh like for example
c6 bc queen b6 d4 is there something
else for what for black that's where you
would return to like i'm very happy that
you spotted rook f3 so you would look at
rook f3 you would look at ed
and then you'd look at this position for
a little while and say
okay but
there's really nothing other than those
two moves
yeah i was thinking like queen b3 but i
guess just c7 i mean it it's at some
point you have to play defense
right that's why it's going to make a
second queen is that the best move after
queen b3
i think it well there's also even
through c3 just kick you yeah
[Laughter]
so if if c6
well the idea could also be c6bcbc and
then we try again but
yeah maybe maybe it's not
it's not that
people in the chat are like what
did we just say
it's a it's a russian expression ah it
could be like a6
and like queen a8
something like completely absurd like
that like
so i i like
i like a6 more than i like a5 because i
feel like opening the queen side is a
separate thread entirely right
and the correct move here
is indeed a6 with the idea a5
a5 is actually also good a5 or a6 are
both good queen b a queen a7 and this is
the and here's the amazing thing about
this position i think this is an
instructive point all on its own
what should you do if i play ba
in a blitz game what should you do
uh blizz game probably take on a6 just
recapture that's the best move
you don't need to rush with queen b8 and
this is why i'm such a big proponent of
figuring out how much time you have in
any given position because white has
absolutely no moves the best move after
pa is bishop g2 and obviously here you
take and then take on f3
white is totally paralyzed there's no
way of stopping this or queen a queen a7
and if you had played like ba
queen b8 or queen a7 queen a8 this is
highly inaccurate believe it or not this
actually relinquishes a lot of the
advantage because white has it's still
winning but why does rook be two
and luckily black still wins d4
e e d there's
e d there's queen d3
and because you're saddled with
that pawn on a6 you have to play ba now
it's still winning but white has this
move and it's a little bit messy
wow
the last thing i was expecting is to get
attacked here
yeah exactly
yeah i know
the rolls reverse
so the simplest here is just to play ba
and that the game is over because just
this is coming and
there's nothing i can do about it
a6 is very nice
yeah i like that move a lot but you
understand the point that i'm that i'm
making sort of about
understanding the level of urgency that
you have to play with in any given like
winning position
some positions you just realize that you
can play slowly and then that makes your
tasks so much easier
yeah
yeah yeah there was a couple of examples
today you have to be quick like knight
c6 knight b4 but
a6 and then also king f1
right uh
that's very nice
yeah you just distinguish positions
where you can afford to play slowly from
those in which you
you can sense that there's like a
ticking
you know like a ticking clock and and or
there's an immediate threat that needs
to be dealt with such as queen takes e4
in the
the soviet position we looked at
i feel like these were also good
positions literally there was like two
guys here who no even batur is like half
uh half russian or something
right oh that's definitely his first
language
so
i do have a really nice end game that we
can finish with if you if you're in the
mood for it
yeah let's do it
[Music]